[Musik]
wo immer mehr platz für papier und
stifte findet mord diego war seine
familie sagt thierry sei glücklich wenn
er mal ob das wirklich so ist weiß
niemand
die stadt ist er kann nicht sprechen
sein umfeld kann nur erahnen was in
seinem kopf vorgeht
[Musik]
eines aber lässt sich mit sicherheit
sagen mit seinen bildern macht er die
andere glücklich davon handelt dieser
fehler
[Musik]
[Applaus]
mein erster drehtag pc über meine kamera
hat eine unerwartete wirkung auf ihn
eine kamera lachen terry cole 88 smile
war okay theorie wendet all die regeln
die er mühsam lernen musste manchmal
etwas unflexibel an
jetzt wo dies geklärt ist darf ich
eintauchen in seiner welt und seine
bilder sein nächstes motiv 42
ja
[Musik]
unter links nicht immer aber jetzt
stellt es zwei monaten vom tribune links
ich früher als sehr niedrig machen wird
manchem etwas macht der räder kommt und
wie gut er mach das jetzt einfach tier
ist 19 jahre alt kurz vor seinem ersten
geburtstag verstummte er
[Musik]
seine eltern lebten einen ersten
verdacht lange zwei jahre später dann
die diagnose frühkindlichem autismus
damals hatten johann und anke huber noch
die hoffnung theorie könnte seinen
entwicklungs rückstand aufholen und
normal eingeschult werden
die hoffnung auf ein normales leben hat
sich zerschlagen und trotzdem die haut
enorme fortschritte gemacht
für shopping horror sie will er einen
sitz alles hat wie lange und glühten
sich genervt dass er das macht
und da haben wir jetzt ein stein bot der
wandertag wechselt hat ein boot kommen
und hat ruhe und hatten oft nicht
flexibel sie sich immer grund hat ihn
das gestört entweder hat mit dem punkt
nicht vertraut und hat dann auf einer
schrägen und meistens was er sucht fall
ist an der boot gewechselt hat
wenn er ist mein freund
was sind das für für gesten 4000 hat das
immer gemacht
viele autistische artisten machen das
anders das gehört einfach aber sie
wissen nie was in seinem kopf vorgeht
mit ganz genau hier aber jetzt ist das
besser aber vorher war das schlimm
diese geräusche die tiere gemacht ist
das singen
er macht das immer ich glaube dass er
das dass er berufung ein der das thema
mal singen aber auch er nicht mehr sagen
man nach hamm minister
theorie ist das zentrum der familie
bucher besonders englisch die beziehung
zu seiner älteren schwester pascalina
[Musik]
gibt es aber noch mal mitgebracht oder
amerika plant man sagen das mache ich
gespielt habe mir das auch so während
sowie sollen das vokabular und ich hab
mir vorstellen dass auch hoch kochen das
ganze stelle mir das geht schnell und
spannend ist natürlich außer zu
musikwinter was er wirklich allein wird
in der freizeit wechsel baute einen
seite ganz kaputt sagt familientherapeut
das sagt die ganze familie war ja man
merkt man ist blind oder man isst man
nicht so gut durch mitgründer ohne grund
mehr das gefühl dass mir strikt hat aber
wenn man in einer diskussion schon von
der stimmlage richtig seit das gespürt
und dann wenn wir ihnen zeigen wie sie
nicht umstritten
und dann verlangten
kaymer lag also der not als die ganze
familie von morgen zeige dass das würd
ich bis jetzt konnte ich mensch mit
einer autismus spektrum störung nur aus
spielfilmen wie reamonn vollkommen in
ihrer eigenen welt und irgendwie genial
theorie aber so erfahre ich nimmt großen
anteil am gefühlsleben seines umfelds
genial indes das trifft auf theorie zu
[Musik]
das ist der reiz der sinne auf eine
wüste nicht über das sieht nix ich wohne
offensichtlich im computer aristokratie
und dann das ab nord hat und wie findet
damals extrem grunde wiener klinik
führer und wo es doch dieser hat mit
doch weist mit perspektive vor dem
winter werdet also mit serbien hat er
das abrollen und lustiger sicher total
us papier werde vom video ab noch das
ist noch 4 2 system xetra der on vom
video der htl dann nochmal ab heute
nimmt er am liebsten fotos postkarten
und bilder aus dem internet aus vorlagen
führt iris eltern sind seine bilder
kleine fenster in die seele ihres
autistischen sohnes
das ist das plateau paradoxie markus
manz erwartet aber trotzdem wieder
romantisch wieso jetzt passiert es ist
definitiv ich habe immer noch diese
kleine hoffnung dass ein nicht artig
aber alle
bis 13 offiziell war
das ist wie eine bombe und übernahmen
ihr schicksal und das von thierry selber
in die hand
sie vernetzen sich mit anderen
betroffenen und setzten des sportes ein
um ihren sohn bis zu sieben stunden pro
tag selber zu therapieren
so lernt der tiere beispielsweise auch
in kontakt zu halten oder sich nicht
selbst zu verletzen
wir mussten jerry beibringen wir lernen
soll das war schwierig am aller
schwierigsten aber war das ein experte
mehr sagte dass ich nur noch
schweizerdeutsch mit ihm reden soll
wie kann ich meinem kind in einer
fremden sprache sagen ich liebe dich
[Musik]
durch die therapie zu hause und später
in sonderschulen ist der flexibler
geworden
die struktur dem sein selbst gemalter
tagesplan vermittelt braucht ihr aber
auch heute noch
[Musik]
filmen wo ich dass sie genau das
abgegeben
seit gut einem jahr lebt die von montag
bis freitag im wohle der zürcher klinik
hier sehe ich das schreiben und rechnen
kann
außerhalb des elternhauses muss tiere
anders kommunizieren mit worten gebärden
und mit seinem tablet es geht darum dass
wir nicht entlastet und ihn wirkt wünsch
von der lieth belassen sondern dass er
wies aber kein ausdruck was er bringt
also dass der satz ist stimmig dann
führt ich denke diesmal womöglich
ausdruck und merkt es wird reagiert und
ihre angst dass das erfolgserlebnis für
die wirksamkeit für das puzzle hast du
schon geschrieben
[Musik]
es gibt ihm sicherheit
diesmal aber jetzt muss ich meine
situation für in bussen fort und will
zum beispiel mal etwas anders gelaufen
ich als er sich skeptisch oder wann es
speziell um grafik ich das wirklich sehr
gut die sich
[Musik]
in seiner wohngruppe lebt die er mit
drei frauen zusammen eine von ihnen ist
angelina sogleich das du anbietet
[Musik]
nick und seine familie wurde und wird
die er ihnen versteckt heutigen vater
und sohn sogar gemeinsam aus
[Musik]
ich bin gerne gehört dazu
möglich ist wie mir für richtig dankbar
dass es bessere mannschaft macht mehr
verständnis für über leid was ist
wichtig im leben und ich finde das ist
wichtig dass wir endlich wieder zeit die
mieter und das hört sich so zeigen glück
hat sich vielleicht etwas theorie tanzt
gerne und er liebt es mit seinem
mountainbike die steilsten abfahrten zu
machen am liebsten zusammen mit seinem
vater und dem rest der familie
[Musik]
er liebt es in kunstmuseen zu malen
das fanden seine eltern vor jahren auf
einer reise nach new york heraus auch
wenn er die bilder direkt vor der nase
hat wie hier im zürcher kunsthaus erst
fotografieren dann malen
warum nur theorie selber kennt die
antwort auf diese frage interessierte
fragen an trug durch finden werden und
das ist einfach so dass wir einfach die
klappe auf
auch im louvre hat die hre schon gebaut
alle hätten gedacht er ist ein großer
künstler erinnert sich seine mutter er
ich bin sehr stolz und ich bin auch
glücklich dass er glücklich dass er
einen weg gefunden hat
wie heißt es die experten auszudrücken
diese nahmen bisher diese paintings zu
andere leute zu fremde leute eher bin
eure namen so wie ich mich im tieres
bilder kennen
so nimmt auch er als person für mich
immer konkretere formen an
seine art zu malen und sein wesen
berühre nicht
und damit bin ich nicht allein schon zum
zweiten mal konnte seine werke in einer
ausstellung zeigen heute findet die
vernissage statt
doch der stille und der idee bilder
malen und es verstanden hat weiß ich
nicht aber ich weiß dass erfreut hat
oder bilder und ein erwachsener sprechen
dankeschön
der abend wird ein voller erfolg
seine betreuer aus dem wohnheim sind
gekommen freunde seiner eltern verwandte
und mittendrin in seiner eigenen welt
die remark
seine fans bediente schon fast
professionell um so schnell wie möglich
weiter malen zu können
bis mindestens ins megaschön dass mir
den messetagen können erläutert nicht
nur meere deutschland sondern dass er
jetzt zeigen konkret auf dem gerät aber
so müsse jetzt zeigen was für tolle
person
beeindruckt ist auch künstler und kunst
dozent emil müller genannt mühle in das
hat er ganz präzise art von verdichten
also tut weil er die ackerflächen malt
sondern linie dann setzte so langsam
dass eine feder wie eine freche wir also
unsere linien flächen das wunderbar
theorie und seine bilder faszinieren
mich hat es berührt wo nicht die
allererste zeichnete chf nicht mehr
sagen hey das ist genial was ich genial
das hatte das hat es wohl so ganz tief
gab es ist wirklich so sensibel für dich
die ganze intensive art vom zeichner das
genial
von jahr betrachtet sieht man in
tierisch bildern nur einzelne striche
öffnet man den blick sieht man ein
kunstwerk so ist es mir in diesen tagen
auch mit theorie selber ergangen
ich hatte die absicht einen film über
einen mahlenden autisten zu drehen
jetzt sehe ich einen wunderbaren
menschen und dessen familie ein
gesamtkunstwerk sozusagen
wir haben viele die mich seit jahren die
haben das kind behindert ist das ist es
geschenkt und ich kann immer die ludwig
auf dem mond seit ich möchte dass die
tiere
ich möchte das ist ich möchte sehr viel
sport immer auf der seite ständig sie
aber muss ich sage ich verstehe das mit
gesang mir findet er diese anderen und
da ist es gesang und wir sind mit ihm
glücklich
[Musik]